taking these last weekend
one of the better Southeastern festivals
of of you know you get the top tiers you
got the bonnaroo's the coachella's the
lollapaloozas the ACLS and in that
second tier Boston callings Shaky Knees
um Hangouts maybe Hangouts in that top
tier now but
um Firefly shaking he's always seems to
come through with at least a lineup that
feels so so well crafted and right in
the pocket of at least my type of uh
musical style taco how was it it was
great and yeah you were asking me like
is there anything like absolute can't
miss on the Bonnaroo lineup for me on
the shakinis lineup there was more more
bands that I absolutely had to see
really cool uh The Mars Volta was my
number one
look at you yeah where's Volta I had no
idea you're a Marvel yeah okay
um yeah so we got I got there it's it's
a little tougher because it is a city
festival you know there's no camping
there's no you know getting in and out
is a major kind of deal just because
you've got to you know get there and
then you've got to leave because it
shuts down you know and uh I stayed at
my aunt's who she lives about an hour
north of Atlanta so you know every day
was drive an hour get on the train
station oh I forgot because you don't
have the bus yeah I don't have the bus
so you know I have to do I'll take all
this extra in years past when you took
the bus you would stay in the bus oh
yeah uh yeah I've Got Friends where
would you park it well uh last year we
had a friend who lives pretty much
downtown Atlanta and uh he's okay he
went chickadees too but uh he just let
me park the bus in his driveway and then
it was a quick Uber from his house uh
downtown Atlanta down to Central Park
so I mean we were in and out easy it was
it was pretty good so but this time yeah
I'd have to take an hour car trip
ride the train for 30 minutes get out
walk another 10 minutes or so and so by
the time I get there I'm already you
know exhausted
and then of course I get there Friday
and if you remember there was a little
mix up with the tickets which you know
shout out to Joe he got me straightened
out very quickly
um but you know it I missed that Killer
Mike show which I I feel bad about I
really want to see and I could no Killer
Mike was the last minute Edition right
yeah Manchester dropped out and they got
Killer Mike to fill in and I could hear
him singing I could hear him performing
as I'm sitting there at will call
waiting on you know to get the tickets
sorted out
um so but that finally got sorted out I
got in
so I'll tell you about Killer Mike
um did I talk about it on the show that
I went to the album release thing with
him
uh this was out of this is one of the
Great Moments that I've had living here
he did an album release in a Brooklyn
church that was I don't know a 200 year
old church it was out of control
beautiful and he did it because it's his
first solo album and you know there was
a whole bunch of Industry people there
or whatever but he's introducing each
song as it goes along and it was just so
strange sitting in this beautiful
Catholic church hearing I don't know
F in
yeah I mean it was just like it was so
weird but lovely and uh but what he was
trying to say is like every word on this
album my goal is the new album is so
specifically chosen for a reason and
um it's a super personal album it's it's
a it's a testament to his life and his
struggles and all this kind of stuff but
um the thing I loved about it is that
the whole purpose of the album is is
just tell ya
through all of the ups and downs of
hip-hop good news is coming
and he left the thing saying over and
over and over just go tell your people
good news is coming good news is coming
he is such an inspirational dude I could
listen listen to him do anything read
anything
proficize anything uh I just love Killer
Mike so so much
um me too yeah and I hate that you miss
I hate you missed that show I hate that
I missed yeah and especially when he
performs in Atlanta like you know
because he's from Atlanta like he loves
Atlanta you can just tell it's just a
whole new level of energy for him
um that's a great Point yeah and I did
see of course I did see around the
jewels at shaking these and that was fun
so I wanted to see Killer Mike missed it
caught a little bit of the Greta Van
Fleet show as I was coming in
um but I definitely
um I don't know it was you know
everybody comparison to Led Zeppelin
which I get you know
um I thought it was all right I I wish I
could have you know watched more of it
but uh I I definitely saw the Yeah Yeahs
fantastic show how was that it's so good
so good I know so much I know we yeah we
saw them at a venue here in New York
called Forest Hills which is to me my
favorite venue in the city
um oh God it felt so good it felt so
good to see her again I I don't think I
I haven't seen them since like 2006 or
something like that
um I love this new album I'm absolutely
out of control in love with the new
album so the one thing that I'm bummed
about is them not being a Bonnaroo
yeah yeah that would be perfect upon a
room uh yeah that was one of my not
missed shows I got to see them so I was
happy about that The Killers close it
out Friday night you know it was a
Friday night headliner and of course I
had to leave a little early because I've
got you know I've got a walk and then
ride the train and then you know drive
so
uh I didn't get to stay for the whole
thing unfortunately but then the next
day Saturday came out and do it all
again
um I saw 311 which was fantastic
and then yeah I just I I can't believe
these guys are still around and that
Nick Hexum still looks like he's 25 you
know he's just as dreamy now as he was
then it's so weird
yeah and then of course Saturday The
Mars Volta was was my absolute cannot
miss number one stayed for the whole
thing it was right up front
that show was criminally under attended
I felt like that it just didn't seem
like there was hardly anybody there
it seemed a lot I saw a lot of your
snaps it seemed like a bunch of shows
seemed under attended
well
yeah uh I think was it a light crowd no
it was a sold out show it wasn't light
at all it was just um where I was
standing well they didn't have a lot of
people I don't think they sold a lot of
uh Platinum tickets which is was the you
know the Platinum viewing area was right
in front of where I was
so you know if from where just from
where I was looking yeah it didn't look
like anybody hardly but you know behind
me and like you know the whole crowd was
filled up back behind especially that
hoser show holy crap
there's a lot of people for that
uh Hozier is the silent killer man
um he sells more tickets than you think
he sells more product than you think he
streams bigger than you think
um uh he's just one of those guys that
you just take for granted and you don't
know how big he really is until you do
you see it yeah that was yeah his show
Sunday was massive absolutely massive
Saturday after The Mars Volta that's the
place to find the mom's Taco
yeah definitely yeah for sure
um I started to go see Tenacious D
Saturday
um and caught a little bit that show but
I ran into a couple of podcast listeners
uh Sal and Josh from Texas
Alan Josh from Texas yeah they they come
back from Texas every year they were
there shaking these they loved the show
um so got to hang out and talk with them
so that was cool they said they used to
get their address they can get something
from Barry's basement yeah what do they
need uh yeah yeah well yeah
we'll see yeah
um they they said they'd do a barbecue
like cookout every year uh at camp
so I might have to find them okay well
okay hang on a second what day are they
doing that yeah no kidding what day are
they doing this well because they drive
they said they don't usually get in
until like Thursday and so they usually
way out in like you know pod you know 10
or 9 or whatever so yeah but uh I mean
but are they doing this if if if they're
doing this if they're doing like a
barbecue burial on like Sunday
how long has this meat been sitting in
that
cooler how long can you really sit on
that stuff I I planted yeah that better
be like I show up and then the barbecue
starts because
we've got some leftover chicken from
Friday oh okay Sunday morning sounds
great they better have that packed on
some dry ice or something
yeah heard uh well good I'm glad you met
some podcast listeners it's weird to
meet podcast listeners in the wild you
know I met
um that one listener out of nowhere at a
bar in New Orleans as we just watched
football and he looked over and he just
and then we just hung out for the rest
of the day and bounced around the city
it's weird to I guess it's weird to see
us in the wild and I guess it's weird to
see podcast listeners in the wild all
the same time well especially because I
was working my way up through the crowd
to see Tenacious D and then you know out
of nowhere I just hear somebody you know
yell taco and I turn around and you know
they're just like Hey we're big you know
we love the show good to see you and
it's like that's great they just spotted
me at just walking through the crowd
yeah that's great yeah the the weird
thing about that is that you missed the
Tenacious D show and then the next day
they announced they've got new music
showing up and
yeah I bet you didn't hear any of that
huh I did not yeah yeah I got caught up
talking to him um
yeah I know yeah it's a tough one heavy
is the head that wears the crown that's
right
yeah and then that Muse show is so good
I love music yeah
um they they did this thing where they
dropped this curtain behind him and
there was like a giant head with like a
hand it looks like it was coming out of
the stage and it would like rotate and
it was just their their stage show and
theatrics is unreal
it is I saw that show when it was at MSG
here uh and yes you're right the one
knock that Barry had on Muse when they
were at Bonnaroo is that it didn't
matter if you're listening to them on
this is a testament to them by the way
it didn't matter if you were listening
to them on stage or if you hit play on
your stereo uh because correct it sounds
so Pitch Perfect all the time and
technically perfect show I've ever heard
yes yeah which lends itself for people
like Barry to be a tad boring
um back to the comment was when it was
over I couldn't hum you a tune I still
couldn't still can't well not that I
don't know Muse has got a lot of hits
and a lot of fans too I mean I get it it
just wasn't it was it was fun to see and
I'm glad I saw it but yeah I think but
to your point
the point the point that I think is
important is that their stage show has
gotten bigger and a little bit more uh
active and and engaging than the one we
saw at Bonnaroo oh yeah definitely yeah
so I'll never not see them
yeah they're great and then so that
takes us to Sunday and I guess the big
surprise for me was Future Islands I had
never really listened to them but uh I
was just wandering around all right I
would love to talk about future islands
because boy I got a lot to say about
this okay all right so you had never
seen them before nope you know you know
that you know the hit you know Seasons
right I don't know that I do
oh okay all right so your first
impression of Future Islands was
um kind of reminded me of editors a
little bit you know he's got just just
really interesting like voice in this
like very strange vocal range like it's
not quite like deep but it's not also
like super high he's just operates in
this weird area and like then sometimes
he'll get into this like guttural like
yeah yeah he growls yeah yeah I I was
into it I don't know I just I just dug
it it is a bat crazy show the first
time you see a berry right
um because it's so performative he's
beating on his chest he's punching
himself he's falling to the ground he's
flailing he'll at one point he'll rip
out his heart from his chest then hold
the heart while it's beating and he'll
look at it and he'll turn away from it
then I'll look at it again and then
he'll put it back in his chest and then
he'll fall down like it's so strange to
watch and then like to Taco's point
he'll go from like sounding like regular
dude into this growl thing uh which is
off-putting but also totally engaging
the first time yeah okay well that was
my first time no the first time you see
the show it's fantastic because it's
just nothing like you've ever seen
before and especially if you like the
songs which I do I love their albums but
then the second time and the third time
and the fourth time you see it I just
look at this I'm like what the is
he doing this for still enough already I
have seen I haven't seen it live I've
seen video I know what you're talking
about yeah
well yeah and I wasn't you know I was
just kind of walking around I think I
was just eaten or something and I could
just hear it off in the distance and I
just that was my first thought was what
in the world is this guy doing I gotta
go see what this is so yeah and I ended
up saying for the whole show
um so it is it's fantastic I love it I
really love it and the other thing too
like he just gives every ounce of him
right he is just soaking wet on stage I
don't care if it's in the middle of a
winter blizzard the dude is sweating
like a maniac because he's working so
hard on stage I mean he's really really
putting every ounce of him into it yeah
um he even said he's like I gotta be
careful I tore my ACL
um so I can't uh you know and then but
then like he would just start jumping
around and like yeah running circles and
he like damn he's uh yeah you can see
why he tore his ACL
it's it's a it's a great show
um but I just I just love the band so
much yeah that you know yeah I just kind
of get taken out of it sometimes you
know after the fourth time you've seen
it I get a little bit
I just want to listen to you you know
that was I guess the big surprise for me
was you know
going and then I went from that to
Father John Misty which was also good
yeah but he's I mean that is a to me
like I love Father John Misty when I
like session him
but it's a different stage show
uh I don't his stage show I find to be
so fun so fun that the Bonnaroo one that
he had that year felt like I was
watching a different artist uh he was
engaged he was uh he had people coming
up on stage he was throwing off of
the stage it was so
um almost Flaming Lips level fun
and then the the just sessioning it
sitting around the house listening to
like oh this is this is this is cute
it's so sweet this is lovely yeah that
show is so much more fun yeah that was
so fun there was uh people formed a
Congo line during the Father John Misty
set and they were just going all over
the you know
it was just people are having a good
time uh and then yeah of course I went
from that to Hosier which was massive
huge fantastic show
um and then The Flaming Lips which was
actually my first time seeing Flaming
Lips surprisingly really yeah
what do you think I mean those are those
are three very like this is the thing
about the shaking he's Berry is it's so
in the pocket yeah I mean those three
artists fit fit like a glove yeah it's a
good day
uh I love the show and of course they
did the uh entire uh Yoshimi album you
see me Battles the Pink Robots you know
from beginning to end which was fun to
watch and you know of course
you know he's got giant Pink Robots
Inflatables up on stage they're you know
shooting confetti into the crowd
balloons you know
it was
of course you know you've seen it but it
was fun I enjoyed it yeah yeah God I
love The Flame live shows um another
surprise it wasn't at Bonnaroo but you
know yeah
how many times can they do it on that
path uh I I really love that show I
really wish it was in the he's in the
big bubble you know versus in the bubble
yeah yep the birth all right the birth
that's a that was that's a great weekend
good for you it was a great week yeah